you're trying to find the coefficient of
x to the 6 there's a long City way to do
this which is it I was dizzy Vanderhoff
there right now let's just remember why
it's a bad idea
yes you're going to have a bad time this
thing you already told me in the
beginning to the letter Turner's how
many times this can happen so Andrew
Symonds forty-four terms forget that at
least the whole point is dou by dou Y of
dude so we started off with student 1
now quite quickly you get two questions
with no other magical way ok so there
you have to identify with a simpler
example you might be able to know which
of the combinations will give you an X
to the 6 okay so for example if I can
find the coefficient of x to the 6 in
this I'm just going to go simple in
columns
ok just made it up ok if the question
was find the coefficient of x to the 6
okay you can clearly see for instance a
receptor that is useless to you this
they will never give you an X physics
example this guy put this because it's
already gone over and then you're going
to multiply to something that will make
the power even bigger right so you can
safely ignore it you can also ignore
this it will be for the same reason but
never get to this guy you're like always
if i pair that up with one of these
terms over here I will get next to the
sixth term one which one yet has to go
with this right if a peasant with any of
the others is nothing you view the same
tower right in the same way this guy
here can also pair up with one time this
is this one right what about this one
too
just want to outline them differently
okay so we abandoned these two because
the powers were too high they're no good
but then you get to this one this is the
last one I haven't done anything with it
I also have to append that one why cause
your commentary or anything because it's
to loitering right to do is that they
were too high this is too low so
therefore I learned where this senator
this or this okay so then if you can
work out the court wishes of those three
pairs that's it those are the only ways
you're going to get next to the six the
same thing happens here okay so we just
have to work out which of these terms
will give me an X to the six okay so the
way that I would think about this is
okay out of this right this part here is
small enough that you can think about on
its own this part is not that's why we
separated out to be a phone question
okay five don't actually start working
this one column the first thing the
first binomial expansion I can rewrite
that let's see it so it's to the power
of three you should know that royal past
the triangle well done by now it's going
to be 1 3 3 1 and then I'm going to do
all the rest of my pieces okay so this
one is easy enough that I think we can
do this together in our head so this one
is going to be the first one it's just
going to be X cubed
how many negative 3 is already hold on
this is the first term there will be
nine of them right but all the answers
I've got none of those episode over
three yes plot that ok the next one I'm
going to excuse or climb down to x
squared which means I'll get my name is
I'll get a negative three okay that look
okay
I've been climbed out again how many
native trees layer this time - mm and
then the last one no more X's all of the
big users Vegas
okay now I know that's wrong but the
purpose would be writing that out is so
that I can do what I did it read here
just now which is the same we want to be
either going to combine with something
useful okay now this is a bit sticky the
example I just gave you I deliberately
simplified it
I had like a series of extras all the
way through okay but if you have a look
at this carefully you will actually get
every single power of X think about this
if K was zero okay with zero or power of
X will come out of this okay equals zero
you'll get an X to the tenth it K is
equal 1 then what power next engine no
no no should this right do you see if
this is 10 minus 3 K I get care the
directed Seven Seas kick 9 and you see
me because of these guys right the power
is interact with each other in this way
that we just give me these nickels
I can see I'm going to get a pack -
you're on whoops equals 3 X to the 4 you
follow you will just sign up that's
before ok it's fine what I'm going to
get here this X 0
ok now k equals 0 1 2 3 4 5 for the
biggest value of K in DC so how many
terms this is so again it'll be 11
starting from 0 that means like a zero
once you do fall all the way up to 10
dot dot dot
I'm so great a for example just cumin
and k equal 6 what will happen it follow
the pattern is ok now remember before I
started say all right so many times is
useful sometimes terms are very good
helping about you get to the safety kid
I'm looking for the coefficient X 6 is
this I'm going to be any good to him no
he cannot combine with anyone that we've
written down
in order to get X to the six what would
you have needed to get next to the six
what would he have to combine with an X
to the negative four
okay so if this expansion had an extra
negative more in it it'd be okay but we
do not have that so design expiate also
a done X to the six
can it combine the company yes it's up
yes which one I mean excellent six
measures up with that one yeah okay so
that good place for for yeah
which one all right X well what you need
what you're searching for is next to the
for what you don't have one right so
this is a good and then you quickly
realize of what it's no good it won't
ever become going to get me good I will
need an X to the sixth apparent with
this which I don't have already X to the
8th to figure out with this which I
don't have
you can stop looking you wrote these
that it these are the only two terms so
that's why even though you look at that
you're like holy cow forty four terms
okay actually only two of them I don't
want you to okay that was a lot of
thinking without much writing okay so
this is what makes it an extension
question there we actually ready to do
the words I hope it turns in here I need
okay so therefore I'm going to say I
you've got them over there um the color
no I don't want to for K equals to K
equals two that'll give me an X to the
six and give you this term so I'm going
to go back it says using part one right
so I'm going to say that T of 2 plus one
right that's my K value so now I'm just
going to
substitute into that one - how'd that
look yeah okay
at this point I need the numbers so ten
feet - I've no idea what temp eateries
are there will be one and then we'll
return and then for 45 good I'll raise
you don't do the X to the six one of the
big there's nothing is so because it's
yeah that's right I can encourage you
though to actually ride one because
nothing disappears is that - once on
Muslims so I get 45 into the six okay
but then I'm going to remember in my
mind therefore it's a 45 X to the six
it's going to combine in that time keep
that in the back of it
the other thing was K equals 3 so I'm
going to give a negative 3 plus 1 equals
10/3 3x to the 10 minus 6 maybe 1 to 10
to 300 ah 110 136 to the small with your
honors attention the area is what side
extremely into my head and then what I
think there's a negative review so sone
820 okay so therefore now I can come up
here and say this is mandatory silent
which is a therefore the coefficient of
x to the 6 because that's what the
question Arctic's not on the whole time
just the number up front is going to be
consisting of this guy and this guy
so how what's in here on that 3 times
minus 3 minus
9 set minus 9 times minus 120 I'm only
just in the coefficient there and in
this side will be negative 27 times 45
1920 1080 and up 591 Kelvin it means
creep 215 it's one to one bite it's good
treatment which is negative a hundred
instead okay I'm I probably really bad
oh yeah yeah there we go
which okay it's an almost number you
also some time is typing like bored with
life so let's just skip after minute
this is a hard question this is about as
hard it would get okay because for
several reasons number one you've got
the interacting with each other which
means there are these escapes terms that
you see that's hard that trips people up
you wanna make it easy there even if you
know to look for them it's still like
the next for the arrows
sitting like that and then over here on
the think really find out what to do
with this you have a we spent ages just
just here and then we worked out what to
do so once you get to that point you've
demonstrated a lot understood